[Music]
cities are a big deal we pretty much all
have to live in them we should try hard
to get them right so few cities are nice
very very few out of many thousands are
really beautiful embarrassingly the more
appealing ones tend to be old which is
weird because we're mostly much better
at making things now cars planes or
phones why not dense cities it's crazy
to settle for this and to leave
something so important to chance we need
to get more scientific and identify the
principles that determine how a city
gets to be pretty or ugly it's not a
mystery why we like some cities so much
better than others this is a manifesto
about how to make attractive cities
there are six fundamental things a city
needs to get right one of the things we
really love in cities is order order
means balance symmetry and repetition it
means the same thing happening again and
again and the left side matching the
right side order is one of the reasons
so many people love Paris but most
cities are a complete mess when it's a
mess it seems like no one's in charge
and that's worrying it's horrible when
everything is jumbled up a pitched roof
next to a flat roof a stark geometrical
box next to a muddled carpark high-rise
towers that look as if they've been
placed at random like teeth in a gaping
mouth we generally have an itch to
straighten things out and when we can't
it's frustrating the same urge is there
when we look at cities often it's not
skyscrapers we mined in the city its
skyscrapers that have been dumped
without planning like they are
increasingly in London whereas New York
or Chicago shows the ordered way that we
love however you have to keep something
else in mind
excessive water can be just as much of a
problem too much regularity can be soul
destroying too much order feels rich it
and alien it can be bleak relentless and
harsh so the ideal we're seeking is
variety and order this is the idea in a
square Intel CH in the Czech Republic
where every house is the same width and
height but within that ordered pattern
every house has been allowed freedom at
the level of form and color or in Java
Island in Amsterdam where the pattern is
quite strict each house is the same
height and width the color range is
restricted but within this grid each
unit is completely individual with
perfectly in the middle between chaos
and boringness here and that's what
humans are door that's what more and
more cities should have order and
variety so as a general rule too much
mess and it's off-putting but too much
simple order and it's boring what we
crave is organized complexity which you
can see as much here as here now for the
second thing that makes it easy utiful
they have to have visible life there are
streets that are dead and streets that
are alive and in general we crave the
live ones
this is a live Street in Hong Kong this
is a live scene in Venice in the 18th
century the painter canaletto
specialised in pictures of cities
everyone loved because they're full of
life there's always plenty going on in
this painting we can see a stonemasons
yard the work shed the rough but they're
charming it's fascinating to see what
people are up to how do they load those
huge blocks onto the gondolas the life
of the city is on display and we're
primed to love this contrast this with a
dead streets of many modern cities today
the places where a lot of the work gets
done looked dull and dead they're spaced
out along huge highways and you never go
there unless you happen to work there
yourself because there's nothing to see
and most office buildings are brutally
anonymous the people inside might be
working on all sorts of fascinating
stuff but we just don't know and it's
disorienting and cold the street levels
are dead contrast this with the streets
we all love where you can see things
going on a bakery a cobbler shop and
market selling carpets a burger bar a
book shop these are streets we love
because they're full of life more and
more in modern cities with hidden life
away we had lots of dead sheds and dead
towers connected up by dead motorways
where you can barely glimpse your fellow
humans rather than the old alleyways
where you can see people at work look at
them in the eye as they
down the road and feel connected to
others modern planners have become
obsessed by hiding technology rather
than trying to make it nice to look at
today we be outraged if we heard a huge
pipeline was going to be slapped across
a lovely river we'd be up in arms but we
book trips to go and see the Roman
Portugal in southern France that's
because it's built for beauty and
practicality we think it's the pipe we
hate it's not it's just the ugliness so
let's make sure our streets are full of
life full of people doing stuff you can
see through the windows that's what
makes certain cities so attractive to
walk along that work is on show that
people are proud of what they're doing
and are happy to let the world notice
and appreciate the practical side of
things there's a third principle of good
cities they are compact in the past
being able to be alone or just with your
partner or family was at first a huge
achievement only the largest class the
poor lived huddled together and it was
horrid as soon as people had money they
wanted to move out and have their own
clocks through the later decades of the
20th century more and more people tucked
themselves away in a private realm and
it's been a disaster it's become deadly
cold boring and very very wasteful on
the environment a compact city like
Barcelona swallows a fraction of the
energy of a sprawling one like Phoenix
in Arizona we built a world of endless
dead dormitory suburbs connected by
sterile wide motorways all because we
labor under the false impression that we
want to be far away from other people
but in fact it's wonderful to have the
balancing moderating influence of living
close to other people in uplifting
surroundings that's why we need tightly
packed well-ordered cities with lots of
squares and public places in which we
can hang out all the most beautiful
compact cities have squares yet the art
of the square has gone into terrible
decline we keep promoting the invention
of mobile phones but no one's built a
good square anywhere on this planet for
decades it's not rocket science though
look at the piazza santa maria in
trastevere rome it's a public place but
intimate and enclosed enough to feel
like an extension of your home lounging
about here having a coffee or a beer
reading a paper you get to be around
other people there moderating cheering
effect is restoring it takes you away
from the over intense
obsessed atmosphere of the home there's
an art to a good square it should be
neither too big nor too small anything
over 30 liters in diameter starts to
become too large by which we mean the
individual becomes overly small relative
to the space around them creating a
sense of alienation and dislocation in a
good square you should be able to see
the face of a person across the square
you could if need be
hail someone walking on the other side
the ideal square must offer a feeling of
containment but not claustrophobia
there's another principle of good cities
to do with orientation and mystery by
definition cities are huge but the
cities that a lot of people love also
have lots of little back streets and
small lanes where you can feel cozy and
get a bit lost
we're drawn to the sense of mystery and
enclosure that these streets offer it's
actually lovely to get a bit lost a
warren of alleyways can feel homely an
intimate that cut a gainer in Columbia
the balconies nearly touch across the
street you can see your neighbors having
breakfast
you know when they've gone to bed or
time the children do their homework on a
Sunday evening the fact that everyone's
a little bit on display a lot of the
time tends to make people nicer they
don't shout at each other quite so much
they put flowers on a table more often
we like it but we forget that we do and
we don't quite know how to ask for it
modern planners and developers give us
maximum privacy because they suppose
that's what we all want and because they
insist that cars and lorries which like
a lot more space than people are the
most important things in the world of
course we need balance between small
streets and big ones necessarily cities
are large we love small streets but
they're a nightmare when you have to go
any distance so the ideal is to have big
boulevards grand wide straight places
and also little Warren's of streets we
need cities that offers two important
pleasures the pleasures of mystery and
the pleasures of orientation let's think
about scale now modern cities are all
about big things
Joseph Campbell once wrote if you want
to see what a society really believes in
look at what the biggest buildings on
the horizon are dedicated to the biggest
most prominent things tell us about the
actual rather than the admitted
priorities of a society we don't
collectively say we worship sports shoe
corporations tax specialists the oil
industry and pharmaceuticals
our cities however tell another story
they're full of enormous towers devoted
to just these things that is a bit
depressing as humans we don't mind
things being big per se we don't mind
being humbled so long as the things were
bowing to deserve homage like a
beautiful Moscow Cathedral or a museum
but we've allowed our cities to be
hijacked by aggressive commercial
interests by towers that honor not God
or love or humanity but pizza
corporations and hedge funds they exist
because we've made a big dumb collective
mistake we focused on who owns land but
we don't think about who owns space who
has air rights and in the end who has
air rights determined to what you can
see from your window we suggest that the
ideal height for any city block is five
storeys high
no more above that people start to feel
small insignificant trivial so we say
cut down those towers and pack
everything into five storeys make a
dense compact and tight like they do in
some parts of Berlin Amsterdam London
and Paris the bits we love of course
occasionally that can be a huge building
but let's keep it for something really
special something all of humanity can
love towers have to be worthy of their
prominence they must be aligned with our
best ambitions and long-term needs
finally make it local some things should
be the same everywhere
we don't expect there to be a uniquely
Venezuelan telephone or a distinctively
Icelandic bicycle but we don't want
buildings to look the same everywhere
it's hugely disappointing when you fly
somewhere for hours land and feel you
could be anywhere the problem isn't just
that we'd like a bit of variation for
its own sake because of climate history
and social traditions each society
really does have different needs
different strengths and weaknesses
there are many distinct styles of
happiness many good and varied ways of
conducting collective life the sameness
of cities is a problem because it
reveals how far each must be from
engaging with a specific character of
its own place it's like wearing the same
clothes in all climates or speaking in
exactly the same way irrespective of who
you're talking to cities need to have
strong characters connected to the use
of distinctive local materials and forms
the pale sandstone of Millbrae Crescent
in Glasgow Southside is a local material
a medium grained copper nifflas blonde
sandstone formed when the Scottish
landmass lay near the equator or around
Cambridge brick from the local yellowish
gold clay is a major traditional
material or think of the way the Great
Australian architect Glen merket found
ways to put up buildings that reflected
the distinctive character of Australian
life so the law should be
don't make your city from buildings that
could be just anywhere
find a style of architecture that
reflects what makes your location
specific the obstacles to building
beautiful cities are not economic
collectively we've got enough money we
face two main problems firstly an
intellectual confusion around beauty and
secondly lack of political will the
intellectual confusion is we think no
one has a right to say what's beautiful
and what's ugly we get worried about who
decides we think beauty is subjective so
surely no one should say anything about
it it's a very understandable qualms but
is horribly useful too greedy property
developers it's such a relief to these
people to learn that there is no such
thing as beauty it means they can get
away with murder we may not agree to the
very last point about what a beautiful
city is but we know an ugly one when we
see it
no one's ever willingly taken a holiday
in Frankfurt on mine or Birmingham and
there are good reasons for this to do
with an objective sense of beauty so
let's stop being dangerously
relativistic about this yes there is
such a thing as beauty Sydney in San
Francisco and bath and Bordeaux have it
and most other places don't the proof
lies in the tourist statistics let's not
keep saying beauty is just in the eye of
the beholder that's just a gift to the
next wealthy idiot who wants to put up a
horrible Tower
the other obstacle is a lack of
political will we've abandoned the
design of cities to the greedy rich
we've given up believing in democracy we
face and have lost the battle between
the public good and commercial
opportunism there will always be a
greedy slick lobby fighting for ugly
development but we can say no beautiful
cities have only ever been created when
governments imposed strict and ambitious
regulations to keep the greedy private
guys in check think of Edinburgh mazing
new town which only got off the ground
because the government established clear
rules to keep developers in check they
were a precise legislation detailing
heights of buildings quality of finish
the width of pavements and a character
of the skyline that's the only way you
get beauty they didn't leave it to the
free market to do that and you will have
chaos when governments give up on beauty
people start to hate all building we
become collectively despondent we think
we hate all building and that we can't
create beautiful places we get obsessed
by restoration and opposed to anything
new which is wrong because we need
places to live humanity hasn't put up a
single beautiful city since about 1905
when Venice was built
no one regretted the lagoons that had
been swallowed up the goal of building
should be to put up things that don't
leave us regretting the nature that's
been lost because the architecture is
every bit the equal of the designs of
nature we can create more beautiful
cities but we have to confront
opportunistic developers and our own
intellectual confusions governments can
only create beauty if they have enough
public backing political will is
ultimately about what all of us the
electorate are asking for that's why we
made this film and hope to awaken youth
to your power as citizens to help
legislate for beautiful cities in the
future these are the six rules now it's
time to fight to put them in action
you